- [Voiceover] La Cuki
Alarcon was late to work
on the night that his
roommate disappeared,
which is why he's still
around to tell what happened.
Outsiders called them all homosexuals,
but the sex workers, some who
lived as women all the time,
others who dressed as
women, primarily on the job,
called each other crazies.
(light orchestral music)
As Alarcon reached the opposite corner,
he could see his friends were still there.
He hesitated for a minute
before crossing the street
and that's when he realized
the Locas were not alone.
Four tall men in ski-masks
were throwing them
in the back of a green truck,
clubbing them with the
butts of their guns.
This was the beginning of the civil war
that consumed El Salvador until 1992.
The United Nations' NGO's, journalists
and scholars have sought
to uncover what happened
to many of the more than 75,000
who were killed or disappeared
during the conflict.
But no one has ever investigated
what happened to Alarcon's friends.
There was his roommate Cristi,
whom he remembers as a gentle 26 year old,
who would bring him
gifts of coats or shoes,
from trips she would frequently take
to Guatemala or Mexico.
Another was Veronica, from San Bartolo,
near the Honduran border,
who was so pretty what her
clients would sometimes
insist on having their
pictures taken with her.
Carolina was so well put together
that she'd sometimes get into trouble.
She looked all woman, Alarcon said
and her clients would get violent
when they discovered she
was trans as she undressed.
Alarcon is one of the only witnesses
to their disappearance
as who is still alive.
But the story of that
night is well remembered.
It's been passed down
from generation to generation
of trans-sex workers in
the country's capital.
It's been retold so many times,
it can sometimes be hard to
separate fact from legend.
Passed down in the same
way many families retell
the haunting mysteries that
still linger from the war.
Alarcon hid from the men rounding
up his friends that night
by throwing himself to the
ground in a small garden.
He tried to slink away
after watching the men
pile his friends into the truck,
but more armed men were patrolling
the surrounding streets.
When the coast was clear,
he went back to work on the corner.
Within minutes, a client
had come and picked him up.
Alarcon figured he'd see
Cristi in a day or two,
which is how long the cops
usually held sex workers
after a routine vice raid.
But Cristi never came home,
none of them did.
Alarcon went to the police
stations to try and find her,
he even hired a lawyer, but
the cops made fun of him
and hinted that his
friends were already dead.
El Salvador's 12 year civil war
had its roots in political battles
that had been going on for half a century
and in 1980, it blew up into
one of the last bloodiest
conflicts of the Cold war.
Bodies were being dumped at a
rate of more than 150 a week,
which the US Embassy
would tally in regular
Violence Week In Review cables,
even as the US grew closer
with the El Salvadoran regime.
"The death squads' victims
"were killed in the usual fashion,"
reported a cable from the
US Embassy to Washington.
"Kidnapped by a group of armed
men who appear to civilians,
"taken away in ubiquitous pick-up trucks,
"shot or strangled or both,
"then dumped along the roadsides."
But those who lost their friends
believe they died because of politics.
The most intriguing part of the legend
of the disappearances from
the savior of the world
and the part that is probably
the most impossible to pin down,
is that they were killed to
cover up a government secret.
They were taken that
night, the story goes,
in a hunt for two sex workers
who had evidence of a crime,
evidence they'd stolen from an american.
Some of the Locas thought
the american was a diplomat,
while others believed he was a reporter.
No one really knew why
he was in the country,
but they all knew what he looked like.
He was a big spender who
always tried two at a time.
The two he picked up
shortly before the raid,
stole his briefcase.
Inside were some cameras
that the Locas believed
had been used to photograph
some kind of government crime.
All of this might be easily shrugged off
as the kind of conspiracy theory
that proliferates in wartime,
except several sources said they heard it
from people directly involved.
La Cuki Alarcon said the
american came to his bar,
offering a reward to get his cameras back.
Another sex worker, who
asked not to be named,
said she'd been warned
that a hunt for the thieves
was underway by a sergeant
in the National Guard,
who was a regular client.
Several told us that one
of the thieves had a wife,
a sistander woman named Sonya,
who lived in San Salvador
for at least another 30 years
and would sometimes talk
about how the authorities
eventually dug the
briefcase out of her patio
with the cameras still inside.
Everyone believes both thieves escaped,
but they're a lot of
different stories about
what happened to the ones who disappeared,
beneath the savior of the world.
They're tortured by having
their fingernails pulled out
and their breasts torn off,
or they were dragged to death by horses
at the infantry barracks.
They were dumped in a hole,
on the road to the
notorious Mariona Prison.
The men said to have taken the locals away
wore no uniforms,
so there's no way to be sure
which force had taken them.
El Salvador is filled
with stories like these,
people turning into ghosts because
unanswered questions are
all that remains of them.
And this story particularly hangs over
the trans-sex workers,
still trying to survive
in San Salvador, where gang violence
and random hate crimes have claimed
at least as many lives
as the war once did.
(people yelling in the background)